colored what do you hope people will
gain from the citizen and from seeing
your character you green um okay what
about the line you mentioned that this
is interesting actually when I look at
the mirror I don't see that I look like
them I don't and they don't look like me
really it's a hep but maybe and they are
from the same nationality or whatever
but you know we we cannot be coated for
what a few of us has done because I
cannot go to Americans for what the
American officers has done in a very
present an era for example you cannot
what they have done it's related to them
just these few officers but they are not
the Americans Americans are great people
really and really humanity must be
enlightened to be protected this is the
only way from my point of view because
if we are one body the body will not
allow any inch of it to be hurt this is
very important we have to get together
the only way believe me
you